I served time in federal prison which turned
out to be the best thing for me i got clean i
rediscovered my passion then my dad broke you out
exactly to kill you exactly but just as his men
were tying me up for my execution i launched
into a performance of my macbeth whence is that
knocking away duncan with their knocking i wish
though because they couldn't get enough of it
i've been doing weekly ghosts for lads ever
since so you're like is jester i can give you
a quick preview if you like an uncle and uncle
now thank you trevor i think we're okay right
now we really just need to find a way to what the
hell what the oh what is that oh whoo what's what
I can see you you're real all this time i thought
it was hallucinating him oh this is such fab news
where's his face he's a bit sensitive about
that Welcome back everyone this is my new marvel
Shang Chi video for the alternate ending and some
deleted scenes the director came out and explained
a couple versions of the ending that they played
with before we got to the theatrical version
so we'll break it down we also got that brand
new trevor scenes well i'll talk about him too
if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos now that
the movie's been out for a while we're going to
start seeing some more eternals trailer videos too
because that's coming out in november and i should
say careful for spoilers for the ending of the
movie if you have not seen it yet but since they
released the film the directors come out and said
that they had multiple different endings to the
movie in different versions of the post-credits
scene with different avengers characters showing
up in a different setting so during the actual
ending of the movie wenwoo the real mcu mandarin
even though as he explained that was never really
his name winds up having a full-on star wars
return of the jedi darth vader arc he and Shang
Chi fight until he's able to show him the true
power of the ten rings wielding the same type of
dragon energy that his mother did at the beginning
of the film and like luke skywalker is finally
able to convince his father that he's wrong his
mother when wu's wife has not been speaking to him
through the ten rings it's been the dweller
in darkness one of the cosmic marvel fearlords
from another dimension inside the mcu who's been
gaslighting him this whole time although there's a
really interesting theory about what's going on
with the capital cities of heaven and the iron
fist mythology that i'll probably do in a separate
video but it's not really relevant for deleted
scenes of the actual ending of the film so when
woo like darth vader sacrifices himself to save
Shang Chi but in doing so passes him the ten rings
like passes them to him formally like here these
belong to you now they're your responsibility
then properly gets his soul sucked out by the
dweller and darkness killing him and if it wasn't
clear they show you his dead body hit the ground
so he's meant to be dead shang chi uses the great
protector dragon's energy and the ten rings to go
full goku dragon ball super saiyan killing the
dweller in darkness so this is where the director
says they had this alternate ending originally
he said that they made a huge change to the plot
so in the alternate ending originally they were
going to have wen wu his father survived the final
battle and he wasn't going to be killed by the
dweller in darkness but they had still planned
on having the post-credits scene be his sister
Xialing taking over the 10 rings organization
and making all the changes that we saw in the
final version of the movie the most notable one
being that she allows women to become soldiers
and assassins like the 10 rings version of black
widows and the stinger message at the end was
always going to be the 10 rings will return as
in come back in another mcu project movie disney
plus series before Shang Chi 2 the sequel movie
so in the alternate ending where when woo was
going to live he would have just left the 10
rings too Xialing stopped being the mandarin again
even though technically he wasn't the mandarin
to begin with but it would have been similar to
what he did earlier in the film when he married
shang chi's mother and started his family because
he still would have passed the ten rings of power
to Shang Chi so then he would have faded into
the background metaphorically not wanting to
be evil anymore wanting to atone for some of
his actions and started being a better father
that was the whole message during their
big final fight as like your family needs
you stop being so crazy so he was always going
to pass leadership of the ten ring to sha ling
but in the version where he lived it would
have just happened in a much more formal way
but the end result is the same mostly the director
said the reason why they decided to kill him off
even though tony lung was amazing in the film
is because they said they were going for the
most impactful moment in him dying wound up
being a more impactful conclusion to his arc
like star wars return of the jedi style darth
vader dies to save his children although because
we have the what if series like what if when
woo had lived if you're a big fan of star wars
else world stories there was a comic book a long
time ago where they basically did what if darth
vader had lived after return of the jedi and then
started helping the rebellion dismantle the empire
he starts wearing this white version of his sith
armor it's just a funny what if version of a star
wars story but kevin biggie said the reason why
they use the ten rings will return message as the
stinger at the end instead of having it say shang
chi will return because a lot of times like after
the first captain america movie it says captain
america will return because the avengers movie
was happening next kevin feige said at this
point there have been so many marvel films
and because of what they did with the mid credits
scene they said that they felt like the audience
would automatically assume shang chi would be back
for more movies so they didn't need to tell them
in a stinger message at the end like oh we always
assumed he would come back the whole mid-credit
scene was meant to tease the shang chi sequels
in avengers 5. with the details about the ten
rings being more ancient than the records of kamar
taj the doctor strange and wong have they're from
another dimension and they were broadcasting
a signal to whoever created the ten rings
in the way they played it it was meant to be more
ominous like it wasn't a good character like some
great powerful ancient cosmic villain i've already
talked about who i think that is in some of my
other post-credits scene videos so i'll link those
at the end of this and down in the description but
pretty much everybody assumes Shang Chi is coming
back so kevin feige said they just wanted to do
something unexpected with that stinger because
more casual fans would have probably assumed
that the 10 ranks organization would be gone after
wenwu died big twist though his sister takes over
sharon carter power broker style that's kind of
the vibe they're going for like his sister Xialing
isn't evil sharon carter is not evil now even
though she's the power broker they're meant to
be morally gray characters sort of playing between
the lines like julia louis dreyfus's val character
the director also clarified that there were other
versions of the mid-credits scene too that they
worked on but ultimately it was kevin feige and
the other marvel producers in the powers-that-be
who chose which characters were in the mid-credits
scene and what they were doing in the big credits
scene all that dialogue like everything about this
and how it went down was dictated by kevin feige
with some input from the director the only thing
the director said that he wanted in this scene
here was that he wanted them to include brie
larson's captain marvel because he'd worked with
her on a separate movie in the past and they were
friends so he just wanted to work with her again
that was his only note but everything else came
from kevin feige but that's why they did the scene
with the avengers zoom call because it was the
easy way to explain how she could be there when
currently in present day heading into captain
marvel 2 she's still over in the cree scroll
part of the galaxy the whole reason for the hulk
being there was to tease what's going on with him
during she-hulk and the reason why they have him
looking like banner again like he's turned back
into banner from professor hulk and obviously all
the details about the 10 rings were meant to tease
Shang Chi 2 avengers 5 and the larger stuff that
they'll continue to set up in the sequels but the
whole thing with the trevor scene just to move
on to that with his backstory after iron man 3 as
he explains he went to seagate prison where they
were keeping justin hammer maybe he'll come back
for armor wars it seems like everybody's coming
back from the marvel phase 1 and phase 2 movies
but when wu's men broke him out of prison during
the events of the marvel one shot all hail the
king during this scene here then as he explains
they took him back to wenwu's compound after this
and they were about to execute him for creating
all this negative attention around wenwoo and
the ten rings but he started to act so ridiculous
as they were about to kill him that they started
laughing and decided to keep him around as their
court jester just doing performances for all of
wenwu's men at the compound the whole thing with
morris that he was the magical creature from ta-lo
was captured by wenwu later in the timeline after
he'd captured trevor they said that he was picked
up during one of wenwu's many attempts to find
alternate ways into tolo the alternate dimension
through the forest and if it wasn't clear
tallow is not meant to be on planet earth it's
in a different dimension completely morris just
happened to be in the forest when wu's men found
him there the reason why he was able to navigate
the maze so easily though is because as he says
he's super old he grew up with shang chi's mother
even though you can't tell from looking at him
and he'd lived in that area for so long playing
in the forest for so long learning how it worked
his whole life so navigating for him became second
nature it's the same thing with Shang Chi's mother
she could have navigated the forest maze with
her eyes closed and even though at the end of
the movie they don't completely show you what
happens to trevor and morris it's implied that
morris stayed in tahlo with the others of his
kind and trevor went back to earth in the main
mcu dimension and they just let him go free i'm
not expecting ben kingsley to come back in the
sequels but i suppose there's always a chance
for more small cameo scenes but i kind of feel
like they completely paid off his character's arc
during the movie like the whole point of putting
him in it was to explain what happened after
this scene and they did that pretty completely
but if we learn about any other big alternate
endings or major deleted scenes i'll include
them in my future videos usually we don't find
out about all them until the blu-ray and home
video releases which will actually be in the next
couple of months so you won't have to wait that
long if you've had problems seeing the movie in
theaters like i said eternals is gonna be the
next big movie coming out in november that's gonna
be a theatrical release they're not making any big
changes to that spider-man no way home coming
out in december no major changes to that either
and the actual good news is that venom let there
be carnage got moved up it's coming out at the
beginning of october i've got a couple new trailer
videos for that that i'll post in the next couple
of days too so make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss any of that
my full marvel what if episode 6 video will
post next wednesday just like normal everyone
click here for my full shang chi post credit scene
video and click here for my Shang Chi abomination
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next one!